this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much Mike and thank you
very much for the invitation thank you
ed and les being fantastic hosts and I'm
very happy to be here presenting this
talk in Cornell with a beautiful fall
they so my talk is going to be about
improving plum breeding efficiency with
quantitative genetics I need to talk to
this side right okay so we'll see how we
do that's better right okay so what I'm
gonna be doing if I'm gonna go through a
few projects that we have been working
on and how we're using some of this
quantitative genetic theory some of
these tools to actually ask questions
that are relevant for breeding programs
and for improving efficiency in breeding
programs so I do like to start with this
response to selection equation okay so
is that better yeah okay so with a
response to selection you know we start
with a population that has a mean and we
select individuals and hopefully we
would like that the next generation
moves forward in the direction of where
we selected and how much to remove that
population depends on a few things and
that is mainly the intensity of
selection so how many of those
individuals to be select the variance of
that population in this case they're
genetic variants that we put there and
then or the additive variance and then
the accuracy of how good are we at
identifying those best genetically best
individuals right and that accuracy
could have to do with if we're doing the
typical ection has to do with a
heritability but there are other ways we
can evaluate that accuracy but bottom
line it's a function of this population
of how much variations we have in this
population how much pressure to be put
into the selection and how good are we
at selecting and I'm gonna show you how
we can impact this at different levels
when we are working with our
optimization strategies we're going to
be using some strategies that are going
to improve the intensity of selection
because we can have larger
population sizes were that are is gonna
improve the accuracy of this election so
we can work on different aspects for
that but before we go there we need you
know we're gonna be evaluating this
individuals based on their phenotype so
what is this phenotype if we have two
different individuals we have the
genetic component that is relevant and
that is can affect the phenotype but we
also have the environment that will
affect this response and how we perceive
the phenotype and then we have the
interaction between this genotype and
environment and all of this is gonna
provide us the phenotype so how do we
evaluate and how do we control or
measure or utilize all of these
components is very important in being
able to identify the superior
individuals so this is the first basic
equation of quantitative genetics that
is the phenotype as a function of the
genotype environment and the genotype by
environment interaction so this
environmental variation right that
causes the same genotype to have
different performances in different
environment we can separate it in two
components one is what we call the micro
environment and this is the environment
associated to a single plant or a single
thought and we know that you know the
same genotype if we can replicate that
genotype and adhere and deer it's gonna
provide different yield or it's gonna
have different on height so the
phenotype is going to be different from
a plant to plant or plot to plot right
and that is what we call the micro
environment variation and we can control
that with proper experimental designs
you're probably all very used to using
different experimental design for
controlling that micro environment but
we also have the macro environment and
this is the variation or the environment
associated with a location and time so
these are my location and gear
combinations for the evaluation of the
same genotype right there assuming we
can replicate this genotype and we can
evaluate them in multiple environments
why is that relevant because from here
to here we're going to have a genotype I
am
and interaction so that means that the
top top-ranking genotypes in one
environment might not be the top-ranking
genotypes in another environment and
that is very relevant when we do
selection okay if there was no gie then
it's just an environmental effect and we
can select in any environment and that
would be fine but if we have this
crossover interaction then we need to be
careful in how we model how do we deal
with as G by E so the first part is I'm
going to be talking about how to control
this micro environmental variation and
this is a word very one a PhD student
Alejandro Volquez in which what we were
interested with to compare this
experimental designs for large genomic
studies there has been some studies in
the 50s using some uniformity trials
where they were looking at this
experimental design optimization but
they were not addressing the new or
experimental designs that we can use now
that we have hundreds of genotypes to
there and wait in the same trial so we
wanted to see how we could improve on
that so what we took is a very large
field of wheat so this were 64 hectares
or 158 acres that were harvest in
rectangular pods and then on top of this
what we did is we simulated different
experimental designs so we simulated
some of the most commonly used
experimental designs and those are they
completely randomized design here
Sparrow randomized complete block design
here the Alpha which is an incomplete
block or alpha designs with different
number of experimental units within a
sub-sub block and then we also use this
period and these are all mental designs
so these are not in the segmental
designs not all the genotypes are
replicated some of them are replicated
and some are unreplicated so they're
called a p-trap designs in this case the
G uses the same number of genotypes as
all this other designs so let's say we
were working on the 50x
mental decide 50 genotypes they said 15
three replications 15 three replications
15 three-year-old of those this one also
had 50 genotypes evaluated but because
some of them are not replicated the
number of experimental units are smaller
okay now the other thing is we also
evaluated this period and assuming that
okay what if we keep the number of
experimental units constant and this is
not a function of we're just interested
in evaluating this population that has
50 genotypes I can pull individuals from
this larger population that will make
sense to evaluate and I'm limited by my
resources in evaluation and that it
means how many experimental units we can
have and that is the p-trap n so this
one has more genotypes evaluated than
those 50 so he's trying to make
comparisons a little bit fair for the
different experimental designs we did
this for 50 genotypes we did it for 200
genotypes and we did it for 15 and that
was to have a sense of because you know
the efficiency is the experimental
design that's going to depend on the
size the actual size of the experiment
in smaller experiments explicit or
easier to control for the facial
variability so that was the logic and
here is the result for the medium size
for the 50 genotypes and what we have
here is I'm showing you the correlation
this is a correlation of a true
genotypic value with the predicted by
the model the genotypic value predicted
by the model and then we have for each
one of the experimental designs we have
a no spatial correction so besides
randomizing the experiments in different
ways we also compare no spatial
correction a posterior then we compare
with an ear one model that means that
we're modeling a one-dimensional process
in the columns and then this is an
exponential so it's a two-dimensional
model in which we're modeling the
correlation among experimental units and
this comes because we
that two plots that are close together
tends to be more similar than two plots
that are further apart so we were doing
this post blocking or cost spatial
Corrections and this is shown for each
one of the experimental designs and you
can easily see that the alpha
experimental design was the best one
okay
and this is okay you know not so a
firework so not so many fireworks about
people have been reporting that alpha
designs are better but they haven't been
compared to this PETA web designs and
this is for a single location right so
for me this was very important because
there are tons of genomic studies that
are using the cemented designs and you
can see the drastic compromise there on
there on the correlation that you get of
a true predicted values and on the true
values and the predicted values from
them all and so there is a compromise
that you have here yes on this one you
can use fewer resources on this one
you're still using the same number of
resources but you get a compromise here
the advantage of this one is that maybe
you're testing more individuals so we're
gonna finish this story with another
paper but for now just keep in mind that
the Alpha design was the best one and
that was for a high variability areas
within that 64 a hectare and also for a
low variability areas and we sample 100
independent sites within those locations
so that we will be covering the whole
area so key messages for here from here
is that the best experimental design was
the Alpha the second key message is if
you look there is always an advantage of
modeling the spatial correlation so
there is always an advantage of using
that post blocking the thing is that
with the spatial correlation in this
there is no specific design you do not
get a skewed us with a fish with an
experimental design so special
Corrections are good but cannot be used
as a substitute for my experimental
design and that was something that was
very important because there is
all this you know theory but now with
all these tools that we have for
modeling the spatial variability why on
earth would we do experimental design
and this is the reason why we would do
them so this is just sitting down before
you do your experiment and thinking
about it for a few minutes
it doesn't take money it doesn't take
any extra cost it's just thinking about
it beforehand and there you go you get a
huge improvement in the in the
prediction in this case in the friction
accuracy you also get a huge improvement
in their recovery if the top 15% of the
genotypes we were also looking at model
fit and we were also looking at standard
error so we're better able to compare to
or genetic differences among genotypes
when we have this type of experimental
design so this was a nice story for that
mic environmentally variation and then
we continued to this macro environment
and then I'm going to show you how we
merge those two so this team a/e if we
have one environment here genotypes
performing here a genotype one is better
than two in another environment genotype
2 is superior this is a classic way of
crossover interaction where the winning
genotype is different depending on the
environment and this is mainstream this
is very common in plants we have it we
see it all the time so how do we deal
with this there are few and I'm gonna
show you just a few areas where we have
been doing this modeling so that we can
actually exploit the G by E instead of
assuming that it's not there that it's
very little
or marginal so the first one was to
compare strategies for exploiting this G
by E when we map when we're doing QTL by
E and I'm talking about two TL by E in a
broad sense not necessary as a by
parental QTL mapping but she was just
mapping quantitative traits so if we
have the phenotype or the phenotype will
be a function of the overall mean the
environment the genotype in the G by E
we can now affect this genotype into two
components and one is the marker effect
and the other one so we will have a
perfect and all the other genotypic
effect that is not accounted by this
marker and then the G by E will have a
marker an environment specific marker
effect and all the remaining G by E that
is not accounted by that marker if we
combine this assuming that we have a
table of G by E means if we do not have
the raw data then we can have a single
test for whether there is a main effect
QTL or an environment specific UTL and
that will give us a peak on either one
of those situations and then we can
separate whether it's magnified so G by
E but we can do the genome scan with
this very simple model so now we have
this model for modeling the QTL by E and
I'm going to show you one of the results
of using that model here this was a
mapping population a Jewish population
in barley we were looking at 450
genotypes they were weighted in multiple
environments here are environments and
here at QT ends and this was for a leaf
rest and you can see that there is this
kitty and that was you know global so it
had an effect but the effect was
consistent across environment so this is
kind of like the breeders dream right we
can deploy it and breeding because it's
an allele that is going to be good in
all the environments then we have this
one that there was G by E but only
magnitude differences because everything
is blue so that means that the good
allele was cured in all the environments
again you know breather stream we can
work on this and then we had this other
kid Young's that had a GPA of crossover
interaction or marker by environment
crossover interaction where in some
environments one allele was positive in
the same allele was negative in the
other environment so in these situations
it is not the breather stream in the
sense that we not yet ready deploy it
but it's the physiologist dream right
that what is going on that is causing
this and so we have been working on this
with us to do with the mega environments
or groups of environments
so this is for the phenotype Irsay not
for the marker it's for a leaf rust the
groups of environments that had low GPA
Farini thrust and the other group of
environment so this is to do with you
know raise specific with temperature
with environmental conditions conditions
that cause this pathogen to are
different but to have a different
performance so this is also very
interesting from the science point of
view so this is possible because we did
this if you ever try to do a mapping
with mapping different environments and
doing one environment at a time if you
have struggle to try to figure out what
is it is it different
oh but it's you know it's here so maybe
we can say it's the same thing if you do
this you have a natural way of testing
for this with all the environment
combined so global QTL can be detected
as well as specific environment
kitty-kitty all by environment and then
I'm gonna show you how we also use this
the same logic for G by E with genomic
selection and this is the work of
another PhD student Bettina Lalo and
here we were interested in comparing
strategies for exploiting this G by Eve
when we're doing genomic prediction and
we were interested in or we were
wondering whether we could predict
across locations years vague
environments or whether we need to
evaluate everyone everywhere right which
is a huge investment in money and so so
that was one of the questions we were
interested in ever waiting for this
we had about 1,500 advanced wit lines
that were evaluated in 35 environments
and those four combinations of caucasian
and years and they were evaluated for an
80 K snips and this 35 environments were
highly unbalanced which is very typical
from breeding programs so this ADA came
from there your Byam breeding program
and you can see G by E here where we had
this and Meg environments in the
correlation across those environments in
their spy plot but they
huge hugely unbalanced data which is
very common so they're interested if we
could predict a year if we could predict
my location if we could use this a
higher level of prediction for mega
environments and the model that we use
is a very simple model V is a G blab M
we call it M for the average if we're
using just you know the Y is my mean
across all environments and then I have
my kinship relationship matrix here and
it's a net experience but we also use a
cheap lab Gbowee model in which now my
wife has all of this our yield let's say
in all the different environments and
now we are modeling this G matrix here
as a Kronecker product of this
relationship matrix times the
correlation across environment so like
an unstructured model and so with this
we were able to get predictions and we
did a few things we evaluated for common
number of genotypes because it's
balanced so we decided to do comparisons
for a small number of genotypes and that
was 100 and here I have the predictive
ability of the G blob and the predictive
this is cheap lab m and this is a
predictive ability of the G flat G by E
if something is above the diagonal that
means that H if I eat more than it it if
it's below then there is no need to
model later and this was offer yield and
you can see that if we do it by year so
that means modeling the G by E across
locations red single year the result sir
makes if we do it by location and
modeling the correlation across years
this was better because most of the G by
E was year-to-year variability if we did
for the mega environment you know
results were not very conclusive they
were very close to that 45 degree lines
but what about when we go to larger
population sizes the thing here is that
we cannot do all of those year location
and Meg environments because we do not
have the 900 individuals in each one of
those but
when you compare it for the mega
environment first you can see that the
prediction accuracy for predictive
ability in this case is way larger here
than in any of these models and that is
mainly because we have increased our
population size so we have been able to
increase the production of predictive
ability by including Marshall population
size even when they are highly and
violent across here across years and
locations so that's one thing the other
thing is that when we did this
predictions and we were trying to
predict by year by location we were
looking at this Meg environment and what
you can see is that if we predict for
the mean of the Meg environment that
means that if we were able theoretically
to group locations in Meg environments
and then predict for those locations
what will happen is that yes we get a
decent prediction accuracy of course we
get better if we have the actual
environment screen but for predicting
new environments this work very good so
modeling giba improves prediction
accuracy especially because larger
population sizes can be deployed but
also we can predict new environments if
we rely on this make environments and
groups of environments that tend to have
lower gie then we can predict truly new
environments so that was one of the
interesting things and then what we did
is we work a little bit in the same
concepts in rice and for this we were
looking at a population that had 637
advanced rice lines in three
environments and this was done with a 90
K chips and you can see some of the
phenotypic performance for the different
traits here but I'm gonna show the work
of a Liana at the animals where they you
probably know her she is around she's a
graduate student of Suzanne my coach and
we were working with them on this
project and what we were trying to do is
two things one is okay what is we were
modeling this G by this
you know three-year data said it was not
as huge as the other one but we were
interested in looking at the performance
of the different models one with with
modeling the correlation across
environments with an unstructured model
the other one with the diagonal model
and you could see that we did get a good
prediction accuracy when we were working
on those unstructured models then we
also included environmental coffee areas
and use of Els models and you can see
that we get a huge improvement in the
productive ability by doing that so we
can better inform our model if we use
the skill data to decide how mighty body
structure is it works good but also if
we use their environmental areas then
the model was even better so we can use
those environmental covariance to get
out just you know predicting new
environments we'll need to get beyond I
yell measurement for that environment so
now putting all these pieces together
right we heard that a few things larger
population sizes are better right
because we have higher productive
ability if we have archer population
size choices then modeling Chiba is very
important replication in a good
experimental design is also very
important so how do we put all of this
together to optimize how we allocate
that resources in the breeding program
and my side was you know this is what my
breeding program looked when I got there
to Wisconsin was this we had six testing
locations in each one of the testing
locations we were evaluating about 20
different genotypes in three
replications this is more or less what
was going on it was between 20 and 30
and it was three to four replication but
this means that we were using all of
this 120 plots across six locations to
evaluate 20 genotypes which seemed to me
like a huge investment and resources
just to get a measurement on those only
20 genotypes
so I started to think about how do we
improve this and so what we work on this
graduates year in parallel solace and
then another collaborator with years
we're working on how do we improve this
resource allocation within in among
location so that we can actually you
know with the same resources evaluate
more lines are having snow a better
response to selection so the next step
was okay people are doing this on breath
remember the correlation was not great
but we're evaluating more individuals so
my thought was okay is that violence
worthwhile if we do this augmented the
size but balanced across location which
is but most of the people are doing if
we have this state of 54 genotypes some
of those are replicated I put them fixed
genotypes replicated twice in each one
of their locations and common across
locations so we will be able to evaluate
G by E also and replication within and
then we evaluate the same genotypes in
all the different locations which is
pretty standard we said okay maybe we
can do better by doing that so we were
interested in that but we also went a
little bit crazy and we said okay
because you know we're confident that we
can model the G by E we're confident
that we can model this piece of
variability so how about we and we know
they've make environments and group of
environments that have a low G by E so
we grouped based on historical
information from my program about 20
years of data we created this consistent
Meg environments across the different
years and then we groped them this is
Meg environment one this is Meg
environment you and then we decided to
create this kind of augmented design but
for the mega environment so my thought
was if I have very low G by E here I can
use this different locations and I don't
need to evaluate the same genotypes in
all of those locations I did replicate
across my Meg environments but not with
it and then I did have this text like an
Augmented or P type design I did have my
my lines and what replicate
in all of those and then the final we
you know had some thought and said maybe
we need to be not so extreme so we
decided to have this moderate med and
it's the same general concept but we put
the blue ones here are replicated within
an environment so more replication
within an environment but not across
environments and that's a different
shade of view so here's the code for
what we have there and we went on
simulating all of this experimental
defiance again with uniformity trials we
were simulating with no the special
variability from this yield based on
natural uniformity trials we know that G
by E because we use a historical
information to actually guide us
guidance guide us and what the G by E
structure was for that intercept so with
all of that we evaluated this with
thousands of iterations throughout the
field moving and for different sizes and
what we found is that again here the
predictive ability so this is a
correlation between the true genotypic
value that we gave the model and they
predicted from the model so this is
predictive ability and then here I have
my six locations and I'm showing you
here the predictive ability for my are
CBD which is great right and this is a
predictive ability in a different sense
in the sense that actually is the
predicted value for that genotype right
we have it phenotype we have a genotype
we're not trying to do a CV cross
validation or anything and you can see
that yes of course we're very good at
evaluating and that's why all the all
the trials have been done with Kid Rock
locations they're very good at saying
what did you not speak value is if we
put three for applications here
they're very good they're in this one
not as good and this is the same as the
first paper I show you right so not so
good this is not frayed and you also
have larger various depending on the ice
region that you have happen to have in
the
from me man extreme ed we overdid it
we went very very bad so we didn't get
any good predictive ability there but in
the moderator you can see that wow this
is looking good and I'm only showing for
the mega environment right because we're
not doing by environment protection here
it doesn't make much sense there so this
is very good the moderate meant
outperform the balanced unwrap this one
but not this one so that makes sense
because we have three replications here
so how about when we look at the
response to selection so now because on
this extreme mad I didn't emphasize that
but we haven't have 102 genotypes that
we're evaluating here right so not 20
but 102 so my intensity of selection to
get way higher for selecting the same
number of individuals so if we do that
and we have the predictive ability there
we have the variance you can see that
with my moderate med we can have an
increase of about 40% in my responsive
selection just by allocating my
resources differently
okay I'm using the same number of prods
but I'm putting them differently and I
can have a 40% increase in the response
to selection so this was very great news
for us and this is we're now trying to
figure out what the best way is to
allocate this and we went you know very
arbitrary in how we chose this initial
study but we're optimizing this how do
we actually optimize for how many do we
have to replicate within how many do we
have to replicate across environments
but within a mega environment so we're
optimizing this strategy based on G by E
and spatial variability for each field
so now I'm gonna change gears and I'm
gonna go a little bit faster on a few
other things that are relevant for a
prediction but one is how do we predict
the best parent combinations and this is
not predicting hybrid performance so all
of those work in
hybrids we're not predicting high
performance but we're trying to see
which ones are the parents that produce
best progeny and the meaning of that
progeny is easily I mean we can just get
the mean of the two appearance and then
we will predict the mean of the progeny
but what I'm mostly interested is can we
predict this 10% superior progeny and if
the variance of that Prussian is small
that 10% is going to be lower than in
this so we did that in the wheat dataset
also and the questions were is it better
to select the best parents or the best
process and do we need to model the foal
variance if we select the best process
and we did it for several traits and you
can see here that for grain yield there
was no difference in how we selected
those parents and three years it's a
very complex trait so eventually the
other - up or you can say that the
infinitesimal model works best or you
know very additive things they are
happening this is wheat right so we're
not we were not expecting dominance or
rather crazy thanks very much but for
green protein it paid us to actually
model that variance and predict the best
crosses instead of the best parents you
know and in breeding breeders have
always been choosing the combination of
parents they have never done this
calling point and I will cross every one
to everyone he always chose who to cross
to who but then when we went to genomic
prediction everyone forgot about it and
we're just you know so it please self to
do that and we show it there this is an
extension of that and we're showing and
this is not published yet but we're
showing how long-term response to
selection is affected by these methods
and so there are preliminary results but
we can improve the mean of the
population by optimizing a few things
here and we need to control for
inbreeding but then we'll get very good
response to selection and then the last
part this is with replace phenotyping
which is you know this concept of okay
why do we want to do genomic projections
or how do we actually implement it not
just can we get a very good paper
because we're doing this cross but
one strategy but one of the questions
was with this needed data such that we
have multiple trades that we're
interested in predicting but especially
the quality trades are very expensive
and time-consuming because you know they
are knowing whether it's a good bread
making variety you need to actually bake
it so you create a door you raise it and
all of these crazy things that take a
lot of time so the question was can we
use this genomic prediction to allocate
resources better in the breeding program
and what we did is we were here first
looking at predictions for a single
trade multiple trade two or three or
four trades and you can see that yes
there is an improvement and the
predictive ability and this is for the
population size just playing with those
things but there is an improvement in
the production ability mainly from one
to two trades not so much from the other
ones these are correlated trades right
so an improvement but the most
interesting result is DIF that if we do
a strategic phenotyping so if we only
phenotype a certain number of
individuals but not the same individuals
for the same phenotype so this is
randomizing who do we score for
sedimentation and who do we score for
protein content okay and we optimize
that so we end up evaluating the same
number of individuals for my training
population but in a strategically
unbalanced assign then we can see that
with this strategy we increase the
productive ability and we can actually
go down in population sizes to about a
30% so by being strategic in who to
phenotype we can improve the production
accuracy by a lot so this correlate the
trades yes animal scientists have done
it for ages but I think we can use them
and especially in this type of
situations where some of those traits
are very expensive to measure and we
don't want to measure all of them
we can be strategic and how we phenotype
to increase the predictability so with
that I'd like to thank you all for
listening to me and I would be happy to
take questions thank you yeah sorry
identify so the Meg environments are
defined as groups of environments with
very low G by E with them and high G by
E across in practice most of the time it
is conducted based on the winning
genotypes in each one of the
environments so if you have cross over
there then you call it different Meg
environments if there is no crossover
the thing winning genotypes and you know
it is defined by the G by E for that
actual trait so you do need the
information from those environments okay
in the case of our dataset where I told
you the old dataset we evaluated the Meg
environments across the different years
what we did is for each year for a
series of 20 to 3 years we said ok how
do they group in 1996 the six locations
and I look at the mega environment and
then I went to the next year and said
how do they grow up and then I look at
consistency to see whether those Meg
environments were consistent across the
different years in in our case they
where most of the time they were not
perfect but out eight out of ten of
their times we get the same Meg
environments so I'm pretty confident
that those Meg environments are true and
not part of my imagination and that we
can you know from next year we will get
a similar set of rankings within a mom
features features yeah so there are a
few and I show you a few different
datasets here so for the oats it mainly
has to do with with the rainfall and
whether it was a drawed here or not and
in that case I do have a little bit of
shift in the mega environment that's in
the oats
in the wheat dataset it was not by
location and this was you know your eyes
a small country but most of it was a
year-to-year and what group them as Meg
environments was weather so we first
look at all the rain and all the
environmental areas to try to identify
that and it seemed that yes rain during
grain field in her you know it's Lowry
was one of the things but also all of
the environments in one of the mega
environment where non so cerium had like
no staff years and the other ones were
scab years so he was actually able to
predict from North aetherium headlight
years and for Scott years so in that
case it was very interesting it's not
easy to predict those because they are
year-to-year variability and we don't
know if it's gonna be a scab or not scab
year in that case in your way you get it
one out of seven years so serum
headlight is not like in other revisions
here where you get it every year um in
the case of barley it was mainly
temperature so that had to do with a
temperature there was some of the
northern locations were there is 200
miles north
so northern locations where hotter and
that created the possibility for a heat
stress during rain feeling so how did
that affect the leaf as well probably
you get different races because of those
different temperature and and they are
working on the racist to see what are
the prevalent races in each one of those
this were inoculated but with a multi a
trace inoculants
any questions from Geneva online
learning speed reading record obviously
but we actually start applying mass GM
what would your how would you kind of
integrate keep reiteration here real
from premier building updater training
models is yeah so so a few things there
yes if we go to that five generations
and we have a just adjusted it for our
Odin our green house and all of that if
we go to that we are going to be losing
relationship we're gonna be further away
so we end but we will not be able to
update it in the field again the next
season so one thing is seeing whether we
still keep how good is our production
ability in those times it will be
compared to seer all right so any game
there will be again because it will be
compared to we cannot evaluate yield in
the green house so so then it ends up
being a matter of cost and how much does
that investment pay off on getting those
I think it's a good idea to try it what
they are also working on is so so most
of the time most of the meeting forum
have implemented it in the sense that
they are genotyping the fixed lines
right and waiting until they're those
genotypes have a high value we can put
them in multiple environments we can
evaluate it thoroughly but then we can
also go on an animal model type of thing
where we're having this cycling or
breeding population that is independent
of our
development where we're just taking from
here in reading ever waiting and then
releasing so I think that it will be
best served in that in that system not
just increases so you could you said to
in just increase you know and get to
their five or f6 and get their sex in
the field but I think that masked
advantage would be in this recurrent
selection type of scheme where you do
that they're a tricky part player
because one thing is to put those
genotyping resources into lines that you
know you have invested you do replicate
and all of those I think that's the main
buyers of of inbred breeders is that you
know they do like to be able to put them
in multiple locations whereas here
you're investing that in a genotype that
it's going to be gone in two months
right so so it's a little bit more risky
and the resources that you can do I
haven't done any work on how this model
I had been playing in my mind on whether
it would make sense to implement it that
way or whether I'm gonna transition into
you know the inbreds and then go back
there it's yeah yeah yeah and and that
is that's actually small we have more
than those sixty plots but yes yeah I
think that that's a I do I think that
genomic production and we're not gonna
get ready of the phenotype we're just
gonna have to be better at everyone
waiting and ever waiting the more
promising but we're not gonna get rid of
any phenotyping we're gonna do it better
we're gonna do it more strategically but
we'll still have to put them there in
the field to wait you should better than
the randomized design but I missed I
missed why because soon that a complete
web design it would be worse than
complete than you said and let me
rephrase I'm not sure I heard you said
that the
so was better that I said that the Alpha
was better than they are CBD is
randomized complete block design right
okay so so okay I think I got it but in
the Alpha design we're working with
resolve all in complete block design so
that means that I still have the suite
replications and they can be grouped in
this larger blocks okay so if I'm have
50 genotypes right in the our cvd I have
15 this block 50 here and 50 there right
in the Alpha design I have 50 in this
block but within that block
I have incomplete blocks okay within
this complete replication but then I
have another complete replication with
incomplete blocks the way it is
optimized is that if a pair of genotypes
are within an incomplete block in rep
one I try for the software tasks to not
put them in the same incomplete block in
the next replication okay and then you
do the same for the third one so they
are still you still have the three
replications but now you have this
within block control of the variability
and if you think about this 50 or 200 or
you know any of the mapping coefficients
you're working with four hundred five
thousand you cannot possible possibly
put them in the same you know in a
uniform piece of land all of those that
will be one block right and the idea of
think of big block I said it will help
you to control for that spatial
variability with it and the reason why I
say it's better is because of the
simulation results not a priori so so we
gain in everything we gain on the best
on the recovery of the best phenotype we
gain on the standard error and we gain
on the correlation between protected and
and true values
yeah yeah so um yeah let me go here and
I will repeat okay so the question was
what was the difference between this
jeep lab and the jeep lab to buy in or
the Jeep lap em and the Jeep left by a
right okay okay so this G blob M what we
do is my why it's the vector of mean
performance so what we do if if we have
a G by E study right where we have
multiple environments and then
replications or not we don't care what
we do is we get the best mean estimate
for the single genotype okay so I get
one mean value for each one of the
genotypes so now the size of this vector
is n which is a number of genotypes by
one right so so it's just that it's a
mean value based on a model that
accounts for this experimental design
and it counts for the multiple locations
but it's just one single Mahler one
single value for all them across all the
environments I mean across all the
environments okay but it's a mean it's
not an average so it comes from that
Mahler and then the cheap lab and this
is assuming like this is what everyone
had done right when they get data most
of the people will just get a mean value
free genotype and predict it
right they will summarize all the
information from that study that they
did in multiple environments as a one
mean value for each genotype and then
develop Gbowee
instead of having that it will have a
mean value for each one of the
environments so I'm always and that's a
very strong bias I have I always use the
mean values and not the raw data
and that is because I truly believe that
the best representation that I can do of
a genotype is the mean value in that
environment that I can correct for my
experiment of a sign in all the spatial
variability that I have and that's my
best bet at what the performance of that
genotype in that environment is so in
this case I have this let's say now I
had 50 genotypes evaluated in 10
environments here it will have 50 means
here I will have 500 means because now I
have one mean for each one of those
environments
does that make sense
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu